There are growing demands for Republican Senate
majority leader Mitch McConnell, to recuse
himself from Donald Trump's at some point,
upcoming Senate impeachment trial.
What I really get a kick out of here is that
there are so many corrupt Trump Brown nosers
in positions of power in which for whom recusal
is constantly coming up.
Let's go through some of them.
Remember Donald Trump's beleaguered attorney
general Jeff sessions?
He said years ago, it feels like a decade
ago, years ago, a Jeff sessions had contacts
with Russia.
Not me.
Not the campaign.
No, no, no.
Definitely not us.
Turns out Jeff sessions was lying and he ended
up recusing himself from all Russia related
matters.
We then had Donald Trump's and still have
Donald Trump's propagandizing attorney general
William William Barr immediately did Trump's
bidding after becoming ag writing and disseminating
that completely bogus four-page propaganda
letter, claiming that the Mueller report shows
Trump did nothing wrong.
That letter became the basis for Trump's national
vindication tour.
Trump's cronies, Trump's family, Trump himself
going all around the country using that propaganda
letter from bar to say, Oh yeah, we are completely
vindicated.
Uh, and numerous legal experts calling for
William bar's recusal when it comes to, uh,
the Ukraine fiasco, other investigative and
criminal matters relating to Donald Trump.
And then now we have Senate majority leader
Mitch McConnell, who as I told you last week,
has been so effective at pushing through hundreds
of wacky and often unqualified right-wing
judges, many into lifetime positions of power.
And now Mitch McConnell has said he would
not be an impartial juror in Donald Trump's
impeachment.
Moscow.
Mitch said he would be in quote, total coordination
with the Trump white house about how the Senate
will run Donald Trump's impeachment trial.
This is like letting the defendant coordinate
with the jury in a criminal trial.
And Mitch McConnell admitted this in public.
Mitch McConnell also said in public, he is
not an impartial juror in this game, a democratic
Senator Sherrod Brown says, there is more
and more talk in Washington DC that Mitch
McConnell should recuse himself from the trial.
Now I really want everybody to understand
this.
This is, this is a really important thing
because they are playing major games with
the terms political and the term partisan.
Mitch McConnell keeps saying, listen, it re
lately he keeps saying this is important.
Lately Mitch McConnell keeps saying impeachment
is a political process.
I expect that this will come down along partisan
lines.
Republicans voting to acquit and Democrats
voting to convict.
Now there are a few things here.
First of all, it's hilarious that for weeks
leading up to Donald Trump's impeachment,
the entire time that we had hearings, impeachment
hearings and the house Intel committee and
in the house judiciary committee, Republicans
were insisting there is no crime.
Trump was insisting there is no crime.
How can you impeach without a crime?
And we kept explaining to them guys, impeachment
is a political process.
It does not require a crime.
They keep saying no crime, no crime.
Now Trump is impeached and in defending a
total farce of a trial that they want in the
Senate, they have switched their talking point.
Now they are saying, Hey guys, this is a political
process.
This is not a criminal process.
We're going to run the trial as a political
process, not as a criminal process because
it's not a criminal one.
They revel in their own hypocrisy.
So pointing this out to them is moot or at
least pointless.
But I want to point it out to you.
So let's clarify.
Let's just go to what the, and the rule of
law say whether a president is worthy of impeachment,
does not depend on whether they committed
a crime period.
I mean that's just, that's it.
The constitution outlines that crimes are
not required for impeachment to be the correct
action for the house to take.
Very good.
Number two, the constitution says that senators
voting in an impeachment trial must remain
impartial.
Now, who enforces that impartiality.
That's where we get into a problem.
It's supposed to be the Senate majority leader,
Mitch McConnell working in concert with the
chief justice of the Supreme court who oversees
the trial in the Senate.
In this case.
That's right wing justice John Roberts.
Now it's really important to understand that
the odds that Mitch McConnell actually recuses
himself are almost zero.
It's not literally zero, but it's almost zero
and it's all Republicans that are to blame
for that.
It would only take a few Republicans to join
Democrats and independents in the Senate of
which there are 47 in total to say Mitch McConnell
can not be majority leader or Mitch McConnell
can not manage this trial or Mitch McConnell
must recuse himself and they would have a
majority immediately.
So as bad of an actor as Mitch McConnell is,
we have to hold the Republican party accountable
because it is all of the other Republicans.
I guess we would say the 52 Republicans other
than Mitch McConnell, who continue to prop
them up and I get why they're propping him
up.
As I said last week and I've been saying for
awhile, Mitch McConnell has been an extremely
effective political operative for the Republican
party and for the reactionary right-wing movement
for a very long time now, and they don't have
an interest in limiting his power because
they're thrilled with what Mitch McConnell
has done.
It's disgusting.
It's sad.
The hypocrisy knows no bounds.
But what we come back to again is that we
can remove Mitch McConnell.
He has a challenger in Kentucky, Amy McGrath,
we can remove Donald Trump.
We talk about legislative solutions, congressional
solutions.
There is one solution that is rapidly approaching
only a 10 and a half months away at this point,
barely 10 months actually.
Uh, and it is just voting these people out.
We can do it and it may be the only way to
get them out.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
And follow me while you're on your Instagram
app at David dot Pacman.
Check in with me this week for pictures from
my trip during David Totman show vacation,